time for roses and rose hey hey I forgot
to pick up my wine but it's so full that
I couldn't she's gonna take a little off
the top hmm episode 4 I would say was
the best one yet
it was there in the wall um you know
Ellen knowing you are a new one
nope am i offending anyone so Monday
night's episode was all about Corinne
vs. Taylor the showdown that we knew was
coming because they told us that it was
coming tonight drinking game drink every
time Korean or Taylor says emotional
intelligence and oh so intelligence is a
really important thing in relationship
she brought out ask me what is the most
unhealthy I can explain when in
emotional intelligence no don't do that
you'll die ok drink every time Corinne
or Taylor call each other a beat and
someone talking about dumb [ __ ] no
don't do that you're dead this is fun
big decision it's the tough decision and
probably the hardest one I've had to
make so far so there was a rose ceremony
and some girls went home main and then
they get to the new nollans not know New
Orleans which Nick dubs a more perfect
place to fall in love yeah if I agree
about that but I will say that I was
exclusively on Nick and Rachel's date
with them in New Orleans and it was
pretty cool
you can check that out an easy online
caps
[Music]
so Nick and Rachel have a very sweet
date this is her first one-on-one with
Nick she got the first impression rose
and I have to say I was a little
surprised by just how into each other
these two were there's something about
her not to declare they were into each
other like him into this glass of wine
right now so rachel says she could see
herself falling in love with Nick and I
have to say I fell in love with Nick
more than ever watching him eat a mini a
oh my god
Ben hey babe he was so cute he was so
earnest it was such an ick vile vulgar
ability moment I'm being very genuine
right now I thought he was adorable Nick
and Rachel had a very normal date which
helps them have a real connection that's
crazy
okay he's moving in my hands I'm leavin
my comments but then the group date
habit and it was not so normal
they went to a haunted mansion and those
poor bachelor interns they were running
around that mansion flickering lights
and scaring those girls and the women
probably after hours of Blues and booths
started to believe that they believed in
a bunch of things are Danielle and I say
that the rose ceremony
yeah they asked the dead girl who is
going to go home from the rose ceremony
kind of train
that baby ghost has other things to do
okay hmm busy in the underworld I need
you and back at the hotel Korean and
Taylor are prepping for their two-on-one
like absolute Queen
Taylor the mental health counselor is
meditating and smelling salts Corrine or
whatever she is is ordering room service
and drinking Corinne keeps living her
best life look how much room service she
ordered for herself you may have change
hands
but back to the group date for a big
confession little Raven from Arkansas
dropped this bomb
actually the moment I fell in love with
you is there a key she do is playing The
Little Mermaid
[Music]
Wow drinking pill silver so that moment
would have been kind of awkward but
Raven did the most important thing in
reality television she owned it to
loosen but I said it whatever and then
we have the two-on-one and the Bayou
with this woman who says that she is I
am over to priestess but dresses like
she's from Chico's so Taylor and Corrine
both talk some crap about each other to
Nick but in the end I don't want to
shock you guys Nick kept TV gold golden
haired Corinne around and then we got to
a moment that blew my life all along I
thought Corinne was a new Chad Johnson
no it's Taylor after Taylor was left in
the after Taylor was left in the Bayou
Taylor went after Corinne and Nick yes
walking through the woods getting a
cleanse and she found them Chad Johnson
style
the only thing missing was the whistling
fabulous
we got a to be continued after that will
Taylor live to see another day will
Corinne continue on in her relationship
that is that Taylor puts it whipped
cream and lies we don't know but we do
know that I still describe up too much
and now I haven't drank that much and we
don't want to waste some good throws act
so
[Music]
cheers everybody
guys please make sure to like ET on
facebook where we do bachelor recaps
every tuesday subscribe to us on youtube
where we do roses and rose' and you can
follow me on social media okay thanks
bye
[Music]